what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off david perot is the
founder of rite of passage this is an
awesome conversation and one that I'll
remember for a long time in it we talked
about the importance of writing publicly
the downfall of mainstream media what
blogging did to transform the
traditional journalism landscape how the
Internet is enabling individuals to
become a self-sustaining business
instead of working for large companies
why we will start to see teenage
billionaires within the next decade
that's right he claims that teenage
billionaires are coming and the shift in
education from traditional methods to
online based elearning courses again
this is an awesome episode so highly
recommend you listen alright guys bang
bang I have a very very special treat
here I've got David with me we've got a
whole bunch of stuff to talk about and I
think that this episode is much less
crypto specific and much more I'm going
to extract as much information out of
David's brain as I can because I think
that he sees the world very differently
than most of you or I which is both
dangerous but also valuable so let's see
what we can get out of this thanks so
much for coming to do this dangerous
were valuable that's my new tagline
that's how I Twitter bio man absolutely
so alright I met David three or four
years ago and I was telling him earlier
that he is one of the few people who I
have met who we had a conversation about
what potential pass he could choose in
life he pretty much already knew what he
wanted to do but he was just he needed
some people just to say hey go with your
gut and then he went and actually did
what he said he was gonna do and like
that's a very rare thing in life because
I think a lot of people have kind of
dreams and goals and things like that
but they don't actually pursue it and
today you've got a whole bunch of stuff
going on that's pretty cool so maybe
kind of walk us through childhood and
and kind of where you get to today and
then we'll get into the fun stuff yeah
so we met at a Starbucks that I walk by
all the time I think it's on 3rd and
something like 48th and 3rd or 28th 28th
and 3rd
in in New York and at the time I was
thinking about starting a podcast I was
living in New York at the time and this
would been 2016 and I would intern in
New York back when I was in college and
I would reach out to people and I'd say
hey want to get together and it cold
emails whatever and people would say no
get out of your college kid and then I
would ask other people for an interview
and they would say here is an entire
block of my time there was one guy he
was the social media manager at Golf
Digest I'm a big passionate golfer and
we ended up doing an interview I'm in
college and we did it at the old Conde
Nast headquarters looking over Times
Square me one of year old kid was just
blown away and the interview went well
two weeks later he invited me out for a
trip in San Diego and it was one of
those moments in life where you say wow
the world can be bigger and grander and
you can actually create opportunities
and access for yourself and then when I
moved to New York full-time I said hey
I'm gonna start a podcast and I came to
you we're trying to say Bob what should
I be focused on here how do I think
about this and we had a great
conversation we did and you were one of
a few that I went through a period of my
life where I realized I don't know but
you know and so like do do what you
already know to do but you're either
scared to do you need to figure out some
of the execution details right but but
in most of those cases people already
know what they want to do right and it's
it's more of what's holding them back
from doing it rather than actually you
know hey I have zero idea of what I want
to do right and so maybe give us an idea
of kind of from that start a podcast
right you've got rite-of-passage kind of
what was the thought process behind
building a lot of the content and the
various platforms around writing yeah so
the first job that I had out of college
I actually got by skipping class on a
Tuesday morning in college one of those
rainy days where it's raining so hard
that the water is hitting the ground
jumping up and going back into your shoe
and I said you know what I'm not gonna
go to class
and I wrote a Twitter thread about the
future of media and I really wanted to
work for a company called laundry
service it was social media ad agency
they represented companies like apple
beats by dre Twitter some of the really
cool American brands and I wrote this
thread CEO reached out to me through
Twitter DM and he said hey want to work
for us and so I moved up here this is my
first job after college moved up when I
was 21 years old and this was 2016 and
one of the tag lines for the
organization was people are becoming
media companies and the organization was
owned by a company called Wasserman
Media Group and this the CEO was a guy
named Casey Wasserman grandson of Lew
Wasserman one of the big Hollywood names
and so basically what we had was we had
an ad agency called launder service a
media company called 'cycle and then we
had a talent agency at the top and our
whole pitch to brands this was actually
very futuristic at the time almost too
futuristic was that you could run an ad
by not through a traditional media
company in New York Times Fortune what
you would do is you would run it through
an actual person and I had done you know
an athlete a celebrity something like
that and then you could use their
reaches distribution and when I was
there I began to realize it wasn't that
people are media companies it was that
people are companies and it was getting
a lot easier to convert that reach into
money and all and then to be able to use
your reach to actually build a company
and so I always had this sense and still
do that reach is absolutely underrated
not necessarily the celebrity kind of
reach but I'm talking more about
influencer access to people who are
thinking on your wavelength because it
is getting easier and easier to take
that audience and build a business
around it
yeah it's um I think I've heard you say
before taking your social currency and
turning it into financial currency right
that's the barrier to that of the
friction has drastically been reduced
and we've seen this obviously on a
number of cases but there is a
difference
and I think what you're highlighting
here is a difference between influence
and celebrity right and so you know what
you think about the difference between
those two well that you know we were
talk about Alex Rodriguez earlier right
so Alex Rodriguez had celebrity because
he was a professional athlete and the
influence that he had as a major league
baseball player was he was in a
commercial right but Alex didn't have an
ability to talk directly to fans right
he grew up in an era where social media
wasn't very popular it was much more
about I have a PR person that PR person
kind of is the interface with either
media companies or any sort of positive
or negative press and so once he stopped
playing it's very obvious online that
he's put a lot of time effort and
thoughtfulness into building those
social audiences now he starts with
celebrity but as he builds the social
audiences he's building influence right
and now he's doing we're talking about
he's created you know baseball bats and
shoes and all this thing to then sell
through that using his audience I don't
think that you could do that with just
celebrity right if you don't have the
influencer celebrities like awareness
influences driving action and I think
that that difference is it sounds
somewhat nuanced but when you go to
actually monetize celebrity versus
influencer it's way easier and much more
profitable to monetize the influencer
and this celebrity mm-hmm absolutely one
of the things that I also think people
are under estimating is how how much
action you can actually drive with a
relatively small number of people as
long as those people think that you are
unique and differentiated and they have
a similar way of seeing the world a
certain kind of belief structure and if
you can actually attract those people
you know if you look at the way that the
Internet is structured if you go look at
any kind of metric the one metric that
we over index on as pageviews so I
always think of okay what is everybody
looking at and then what is the big kind
of dark energy in the world that people
are actually missing and not able to
measure and the big one because we look
at pageviews the flip side to that is
that we're not able to really measure in
precise ways
what influence looks like and how strong
these shared bonds and connections can
be online I remember back when I was in
college I used to as my nighttime ritual
watch a watch the casein a stat video
Casey nice that was a youtuber had
500,000 YouTube subscribers and then on
his 35th birthday one year he said I am
going to make a video every single day
and he did it for something like 550
days in a row Wow one of the single
biggest sources of inspiration for me
and I had a relationship with Casey that
was so deep that I remember sometimes
hanging out with people and saying how
is it that I can see you every single
day we can be in the same kinds of
social groups and yet I know more about
what's happening in Casey neistat's life
I feel a stronger emotional attachment
to him and I moved to New York because I
wanted to be like Casey and that was one
of the first moments in my life that I
realized that what's called these
parasocial relationships could be so
strong and so powerful yeah and I think
part of it also is the content that you
consume from both of those relationships
right so if you almost kind of think of
one is a virtual relationship and it's
kind of one directional right like he's
sending you content and you're consuming
that content whereas if you and I get
together for a coffee or something
it's a bi-directional relationship we're
both sending and receiving information
well in that bi-directional relationship
one you're getting feedback on the
content you're sending me but you're at
the same time simultaneously having to
consume the content that I'm sending you
right so it's a little bit more noise in
that content consumption in the
obviously in the One Direction obviously
you're just consuming but he's is also
heavily edited right so there's a a
bench there's the ability to tell a
story there's an emotional kind of
channel and direction that that content
is and so although you might only spend
five or ten minutes with Casey Ness that
or somebody else today would do the
content they post online it's very much
focused on a specific
kind of end goal writer optimized for
something versus if you and I get
together for coffee it's unlikely that
one I'm gonna be able to kind of live
edit the conversation and two you don't
have as much kind of you know input
output that's a little bit distracting
and so I think that that plays into it a
little bit but also you're choosing to
consume KC's content day after day after
day after day because obviously you see
something that is value there right and
I think it's a big big piece of it it
moved me I mean to watch somebody who
was obviously doing what they wanted to
be doing what Casey nice that is just a
really hits my soul when I talk about
him because you're looking at somebody
who had his first kid when he was in
high school he ran away from home as a
high schooler didn't go to college was
working New York as a dishwasher and if
you look at some of the work that he was
doing in 2004-2005 some of the stuff
that he was doing even a little bit
later when the first iPhone came out he
was making these videos where rather
than pointing the camera outwards as had
basically been the entire history of
film he had turned and rotated the
camera a hundred eighty degrees and
focused it on himself and he ended up
actually telling these stories about his
own life long before vlogging was a
thing and the biggest thing I learned
about Casey nice that and I wonder if
this is something that you feel with
crypto is that you can know that
something is the future long before the
world actually accepts that it is and
there's a kind of dogged persistence
that I really admire from people who
have a belief a definite vision about
what the world is going to look like and
they show up day after day after day
even though they get beaten down by the
world told that they can't do it even
when strife comes and misfortune happens
in your life and they keep showing up
and I really admire the success that
he's had because of that when I think we
return my here's conviction and
persistence right so the the conviction
component of it I don't know Casey's
exact story but I'm sure that Casey
didn't feel like he was the only person
who saw this right he actually probably
was able to find a small group of
friends who also
believed that hey you know flipping that
camera around vlogging also was gonna be
a thing but to is it's not how many
people believe it it's how deep the
conviction is this is what I found right
so let's say that you know 1% of the
world's population believe something
well if they really really believe it I
think that makes it much easier to see
well eventually everyone else will bleed
but if 1% of the world kind of sort of
believes it but you know tomorrow we may
all wake up and go somewhere else and do
something else yeah a little bit harder
to get you know kind of your head around
like I'm gonna go do this full-time and
be persistent with it so I think the
level of conviction is really important
regardless of the size of the audience
but then that leads to persistent so if
you really really believe something then
it's much easier to show up day after
day after day and Marty bent is the name
he goes by but but Marty said to me he's
work at Marshall sports and I said to
him one day I said you know what's the
one thing that you learned while
watching kind of barstool get built into
at the time you're about a hundred
million dollar company and he said
showing up every day right he's like
look you know you're not to have your
best day every day but just showing up
and and so many people along the way say
yeah I'm gonna go do something else
right I did this for 20 days 30 days I'm
gonna go do something else but it's that
that constant persistence I think that's
really valuable and I think that is
something that you're doing one kind of
on all the content you're creating but
also to you're now teaching people about
writing right and and the writing the
part to me that's so interesting is
you've really got this conviction that
writing is one of the biggest leverage
things that a human can do in today's
world like explain kind of where that
came from and why you believe that yeah
I believe that writing is the biggest
source of leverage that is also open to
everybody anyone with an internet
connection who has access to ideas and
the time to sit down and put their
fingers on glass can actually publish
something and reach the world with it
now there's a lot more to that there's
strategy and there's tactics but what
I've realized is I have seven months of
corporate experience I have no
credentials to my name I was a B and
see student I graduated from college
with a 2h from high school with the 2/7
and my whole life has been about I I
grew up just feeling like I was stupid
like I wasn't gonna go anywhere and it
was because all of the traditional
system just didn't work for me like I
would go to class they would tell me to
do things and I can't memorize things I
I'm not very extremely stubborn in
things that I want to be doing but I'm
not very good at sort of following
directions and stuff and I have some
kind of just weird mind where sometimes
things let go a little bit too fast and
I'm not detail oriented and then at
other times like in certain math classes
I was like this is going way too fast I
can't do this
and I felt this desperate yearning for
the first two decades of my life of this
feeling of perpetual inadequacy and it
was through writing that I finally felt
like some of the things that had always
felt like strengths that I or weaknesses
that I wanted to run away from actually
became strengths that I could embrace
and I felt like through this kind of
creative outlet I could publish
something and actually think through
ideas at a deeper level because words on
a page just have infinite patience what
you can actually do is by writing things
you actually become smarter because a
lot of the storage that you would have
almost the storage of ideas that you
would have to hold in your head you can
kind of outsource them to the page and
then begin to soak deeper into the ideas
that you're thinking about and so to go
back to my writing journey what was wild
to me was to have not had you know it's
in college in North Carolina and I
always felt like I couldn't meet people
who I could talk about ideas with I
loved ideas I just I'm desperate I have
this yearning hunger and thirst for new
ideas new ways of looking at the world
but until I started writing I wasn't
able to meet people who I could share
that with and all of a sudden I would
after he years really about about two
years things began to change a little
bit the first instances of positive
back was through Twitter when I would
direct message people in New York and I
would say oh my goodness I can meet
people that are also interested in ideas
and then as I kept on writing I had
interesting people actually reaching out
to me I've been doing this for three
years and I am now able to meet people
and work on different projects with
people that I never thought I'd be doing
this in my life and I'm doing it here at
25 who's the most interesting person you
think you've met Patrick Collison at
stripe why Patrick Collison is an
amazing person um he grew up in the
Western Western Ireland and he grew up
without a lot of internet connection and
he came to America started a company I
think sold it for four or five million
dollars and then him and his brother I
think he was either at MIT or Harvard
they dropped out again and they started
stripe and there's a couple things that
I really admire about stripe one of the
first things that patrick has done is I
think of him almost as an idea archivist
you know so often we're looking for the
next new thing and what I've learned
from Patrick is that there's actually a
lot of virtue into going back in time
and looking at the ideas that have been
forgotten one of the ideas that I'm
obsessed with is if you take the
difference between the year 1820 and
2020 what has happened is we've shifted
from a space bias to a time bias so let
me explain what this means in 1820 if
you wanted to go find a new way of
living a new idea what would you do you
would try to hop on some kind of boat
and you would sail to a faraway place
and you would know that when you got off
the ship you would see a way of living
here a language eat foods that you never
even imagined now if you try to go
travel the world I always say a lot of
travel now is seeing things with our own
eyes that we've already seen on
Instagram so where do we find the new
ideas well social media creates this
idea that I call a never-ending now I
was in a limo or a kind of SUV that one
of my friends had called and we
we're going to some comedy club on 17th
and 3rd in New York and we were leaving
from Tribeca and the entire car ride I
was watching what was on the phones of
the six people in front of me and every
single person consumed either a text
message or a story from Instagram or
snapchat and what I realized was say we
had 20 people and 20 minutes in that car
six people so we had about a hundred
twenty minutes worth of human attention
that was only spent on things that were
produced in the last 24 hours
if you had gone back to 1822 a library
the vast majority of those ideas would
have been produced at least a decade
before or hundreds of years ago
and now what social media is doing is it
is having us much more consuming things
that are made in the present I call this
the never-ending now so now the way to
find good ideas is to go back in time
you go back and if to get back to
Patrick Hall's and he's studying the
Apollo program what were they doing
differently he's looking at some of the
Silicon Valley movements like Xerox PARC
and he's trying to study what were the
organizational dynamics of this place
that actually led to some incredible
inventions and then he's bringing those
ideas into the present moment at stripe
and it's one of the reasons that stripe
you walk in there it's a special place
filled with energy and I don't know if
there's a company in the world that more
of my friends want to work for it than
stripe really yeah and do you feel like
that's because it's the culture the
leadership accommodation like why do so
many people want to work there I think
it's the culture they have an amazing
both writing heavy and intellectual
culture they have a yes they are a
payments company but their grand
ambition is to increase what they call
the GDP of the internet and one of the
things that you see with stripe is that
it's a very kind place and I think that
that comes from Patrick's Irish
background I was talking with go to
Ireland a couple months and I was
talking to a friend and he said you're
gonna see a level of kindness here in
Ireland a jolly love that is sort of in
the ether there and I actually feel the
same thing at stripe it's a very Irish
place that's pretty cool
let's talk about rite of passage yeah so
you created a course that teaches people
how to write and at the top level or
kind of high level when you hear that I
think other people say like what does
that mean right I took writing in school
I took English class etc I want you
before you explain exactly how the
course works and kind of what what you
guys have been able to accomplish so far
tell the origin stories I think it's
pretty cool how how this came together
yeah so I was doing some just different
consulting projects in New York and
there is a major business opportunity
that will exist for the next very many
years which is productized consulting so
let me explain that so what most
consulting has been traditionally is you
get hired
you're on retainer or something and you
have some kind of problem that you're
very good at solving you go to the
office of that person and you give the
same answer over and over and over again
I was with a friend he works for one of
the big four consulting firms we were
together last week and I said hey what
do you do for a living like really what
do you do he said well I fly to a
different city every single week and I
have people answer the same 20 questions
about security and then we have a
playbook of things that we do and so
what I was doing was I was helping
different people mostly financial
writers try to build their online
websites and I would say the same things
over and over and I have this obsession
with new ideas so doing the same things
over and over again drives me crazy
so I said you know what I'm gonna make a
course I had taken a course called
building a second brain by Thiago Forte
sort of a note-taking app or note-taking
system and that actually changed my life
phenomenal course might change your life
yeah I'll tell you why because the best
way to improve your writing is not this
is what everybody does and this is why
people are like Sisyphus climbing up a
hill when it comes to writing two steps
up one step back is what most people try
to do is they look for writing books
written by Stephen King and stuff like
that we're gonna go read on right
and then I'm gonna write the next great
American novel and the the it doesn't
work because really what writing what at
least non-fiction writing is at its
deepest atomic level is it is having
interesting ideas and actually
communicating them in ways that are both
insightful and entertaining you do an
amazing job of this right you have your
ideas and you are able to explain them
to bigger audiences than most people who
are in the crypto world that you run in
and so once I had all of these notes in
my pocket all of my writer's block
disappeared I was able to actually not
have the limitations of my brain be a
problem anymore all of a sudden I could
actually think with a computer and use
that to kind of come up with interesting
ideas and so once you go through that
course did you know that hey I want to
create a course or was it through other
conversations like like how do you get
from wow this course was really powerful
and really valuable to me to hope I have
ideas that I want to create a course for
and help others yeah so there there's
one thing that really stuck out so I was
saying the same things to people over
and over again and I sent out a tweet I
said that my goal in 2019 at the time
was to help a thousand people start
writing and there was this tsunami of
responses people were direct messaging
me I got hundreds of replies from people
saying I want to do that and I took a
step back and I said well how do I
actually do this in a way that could be
somewhat scalable because what's great
about scalability is it allows you to
invest more in the thing that you can
scale so I called Thiago whose class I
had taken I said hey let's make this
course flew down to Mexico in the last
week of February 2019 we brought we flew
down a film crew from Hollywood and we
spent 10 days coming up designing an
entire curriculum for a course putting
it together and then
we have now done a couple different
versions and each one just gets better
and better and better because we have a
lot of built-in feedback loops and a
phenomenal community of people who are
some of the most intellectually curious
people in the world and so the park to
me that's so interesting about this
course right is if somebody comes in and
says I want to learn how to write it
doesn't matter if they're already
writing or they know nothing about
writing you guys have a combination of
pre-recorded videos and kind of live
classes or supporting community
why add those two components together
because when I think of online courses I
think of the Coursera is you know the
world where somebody went in a room
whether it was one day or took them you
know year they recorded a bunch of
videos they sequentially put them
together
I buy my course I watched the first
video second video third video and by
the time I'm done I've you know consumed
the content that they created there's no
community there there's kind of no live
components there's no ability to ask
questions it's just again one-way
content consumption you do it the other
way why yeah I want to sort of add one
thing to this before I answer that
question and I say that it's an online
writing course because it's easy to
communicate but you have an audience
that's it's really gonna understand this
what we're really teaching people to do
and writing is the mechanism through
which we're doing this is we're teaching
people how to become citizens of the
internet so what does that mean I
believe that the Internet is a
fundamentally new way of being it is a
new way of thinking about how to connect
with people ideas and opportunities and
what we don't just do is we don't just
teach people how to write we teach them
how to actually think about what we call
a personal monopoly what are you gonna
be known for what is the unique
combination of skills personality traits
and stuff that you're gonna be known for
how are you going to actually use the
internet to actually reach out connect
with anybody as one of our modules and
then how do you actually build what we
call an online home and these
serendipity vehicles for yourself and
use the internet to really advance your
career but now to answer your question
the big thing that platforms like
Skillshare and masterclass and Coursera
get miss is that education and learning
is extremely difficult and when you add
in both learning to write and the actual
act of writing I mean if you just think
of all this mythology around writing
it's extremely difficult and when you
add in a kind of social community it's
one of the things that traditional
education gets absolutely right when you
are with peers you work harder you're
able to actually push through things
more and the analogy that I've been
using is that it's the difference
between a self-paced courses of
everything as pre-recorded is like a
cantilever bridge I grew up in San
Francisco and during the 1989 Loma
Prieta earthquake the bay bridge
actually collapsed room that was screwed
in with nuts and bolts and stuff like
that and the Golden Gate Bridge which
was a suspension bridge it could kind of
swing and it would swing whenever the
you know when the earth was shaking but
it was able to stand up pretty well and
that community is that suspension bridge
everyone can't kind of support each
other and when times get difficult and
stuff the whole community comes together
and so not only are we teaching people
how to write together but we are
producing friendships that would never
be created with these self-paced courses
explain the personal monopoly things
that's a really interesting way to think
about kind of expertise or or branding
it sounds like to some degree like what
what does that mean yeah so Peter teal
in his book zero to one has this very
contrarian idea that all successful
businesses are based on a monopoly and I
wrote a very long essay where I'd of
into basically the metaphysics of teals
thinking and one of the things that you
see time and again with teal is that you
want to avoid competition always so you
want to differentiate yourself and it's
the same thing with what your career is
when I was in college I remember my
senior year of college I walked into our
College job fair this is one of those
big turning points for me Friday
afternoon and I was a hot day just want
to be out and partying having a good
time and I put on a suit walked into
this job fair and there were all these
companies and you had all of these
people walking around with their blue
pencils their red pens their black note
books and then the same tired looks on
all their faces and there were all these
companies but they were basically from
the same couple industries right there
were these management consulting firms
investment banking all this sort of
stuff you know we're told like the
entire top of the pyramid for
undergraduate education you know in 2007
half of Harvard graduates went into
either Investment Banking or management
consulting so what we have is everyone's
sort of going for the same thing and
what I say what the personal monopoly is
stop doing that go find your own thing
your own unique combination of different
personality traits say that you're super
funny or say that you really like Star
Wars and then you also really like
crypto then you kind of combine crypto
Star Wars and being funny and you're
sort of the one person who has that
unique combination of traits because
once you begin to overlap skills then
you're competing with fewer people but
this is where things get really
interesting and this is actually what
you without knowing it did an
exceptional job with and I've looked at
people like you to sort of build out
this theory there's a three step process
I didn't know I was getting
psychoanalyze today but basically I mean
it's people in crypto have done this
over and over again but what you want to
do is you want to pick a small but
growing market that is underestimated so
you go pick a market that like crypto
that would be a very small market but we
know it's growing and all of a sudden
actually not knowing things flips from a
disadvantage to an advantage you have a
fresh perspective that the people that
you're competing against don't then you
go you go learn obsessively about that
industry you read everything you can you
talk to every single person you watch
all the videos and then you learn all
that stuff and you share as much as you
can
and over time you actually begin to
attract people based on your own kind of
learning and the big thing there the big
flip for people is people wrongly think
that you need to be an expert to write
about something know writing is the way
that you learn about the thing that then
you become an expert in yeah to me one
of the things I enjoy about writing and
I think a lot of others and I see that
you do this as well
is that when you write something and put
it out into the world what you're
actually doing is you're eliciting
feedback right you're eliciting
critiques you're listening agreement
right it's very much hey I wrote this
thing this is what I believe based on
the information in facts that I have
today combined with my analysis opinions
etc the best part about writing I write
every single morning is the people who
respond yes and they agree or disagree
right and to me that the disagreements
or the the valuable ones because what
they do is they say hey I saw you said a
B and C a and B make sense to me see
doesn't make sense here's three other
data points that I would consider and
rather than say C I would say you know
XY and Z and you're like you know what
actually like maybe I don't fully jump
to you know your perspective on the
world but you can move me closer to that
direction but you only have one brain
right I only have one brain and so when
you only have one brain thinking about
something it's much more difficult and
as much less likely you're going to get
kind of the right answer than if you
have a bunch of people right I think
it's was the book super forecasters
where it's basically like the crowd is
much better at eliciting kind of the
correct answer than just one person
mm-hm and writing although you're it's
usually one person creating the content
what you're doing is you're throwing it
out there for analysis right and
feedback to a very very large audience
if P were paying attention yes exactly
so one of the things that we have in
it's funny that you say that because I
agree so strongly that I think that at
in rite-of-passage worth the frontier of
thinking about how to elicit feedback so
we have this acronym called cribs crates
are I be s
and whenever you are looking into the
world trying to get feedback on your
ideas you evaluate with CRI BS cribs you
look for things that are confusing
repeated insightful boring or surprising
those are the five things that basically
encompass everything that you say if
something is confusing you rewrite it if
something is repeated you delete it if
something is insightful you talk about
it more if something is boring you
delete it or you rewrite it and if
something is surprising all good writing
has a twist a kind of moment in the
middle where something begins to change
and just like a horror movie you build
up that suspense and then you flip it
and that kind of feedback is something
that people with online audiences really
understand that you're putting signals
out into the world that you earnestly
think are accurate but then at the same
time you are humbled by the fact that
the actual wisdom of all the people who
read your stuff is is more intelligent
than you are but you become more
intelligent as a result of their
responses for sure and I guess one of
the things that you're doing right is
you're giving people a skill which also
giving them confidence right and what
that does is if you believe that every
person becomes a media company or a
company it's almost like
entrepreneurship training to some degree
right because if everyone's gonna be a
media company well you need the skill
and as you do that why is that important
to society right to me it's I think we
both agree that you know quote unquote
media is broken
meaning more of the mainstream media and
we can get into why that is but why is
it important to society that individuals
have that voice and have that ability to
write and share ideas etc because there
are and I've met a lot of them a lot of
them are my friends there are some
people who are unbelievably intelligent
who just don't share anything and one of
the great tragedies of the last five
years is that many of the world's
smartest people are no longer sharing
their ideas in public will be some
examples like Marc Andreessen you had a
state of my mind - you had Marc
Andreessen tragically so Marc ed recent
was the guy who got me interest
90's junior year of college I was
following Marc Andreessen and I would
add that on Twitter and I had this
moment like I could either go to my
class or I could read Marc Andreessen
thoughts in my pocket like to somebody
in rural North Carolina there that was
magical I mean it felt like straight out
of a Disney movie and now the guy
doesn't tweet anything except for quotes
after somebody dies and it's it's it's
tragic but you know that he's in
telegram groups you know that he's in
other groups speaking privately and I
believe that like I have a lot of
students who worry that it's arrogant if
they go start writing Who am I to start
sharing my ideas why should people think
there why should people listen to me and
it's kind of this imposter syndrome this
kind of fear lack of confidence see it
all the time with my students and what I
tell them time and again is it's
arrogant for you to do the hard work of
learning things and not share it with
the world this world progresses when
people share ideas look around you
everything was built by people who came
before you and every single thing was
somebody's obsession from the way that
the buildings were constructed to the
letters on the building in front of us
to the actual construction of the glass
on the iPhone case Johnny I've lived for
that and if you didn't have Johnny I of
the lead designer at Apple actually
going out and putting in with his own
two fingers to actually construct
something for the world to behold it's
the same thing with information it is
arrogant to have ideas in your brain
that could move the world forward and to
not codify them so that the world can
benefit well and part of this I think is
there's a lot of people who think they
don't have ideas right there's a lot of
people who are scared to share the ideas
that they do have and there's a lot of
people who are scared of having ideas
sharing the ideas and getting negative
feedback right and none of those three
things are to me at least are a big
enough obstacle to not share the ideas
in crisis so they're all kind of
short-sighted
why do you think the regular media is
somewhat broken like what like what's
changed over the last I don't know 10 15
years right where we went from the
mainstream media was the say all be all
kind of the you know the law of the land
if you will when it came to content to
today there's a lot of people who would
just say hey I trust somebody else other
than the mainstream media yeah I thought
a lot about this you've probably thought
about it more than anyone I know so I
want to hear you answer I'm obsessed
with this question and I think that a
lot of the narrative around media is
that the media has given us truth and I
don't think that the media has ever
given us truth okay why the media has
given us consensus they're very
different things the best analogy for
this is rowers in a boat so if you look
at a boat and you say you're in a canoe
and you have two or three rowers well
everyone can sort of row at their own
pace and the boat can kind of move
forward but then there's a kind of
critical mass a speed that you need to
go at where all of a sudden if you look
at a boat with ten people in it you need
a coxswain you need somebody who says
stroke stroke stroke and the media was
the coxswain and so the goal wasn't
what's more important is for everybody
to be aligned than to move at the exact
perfect speed right one sort of or that
gets stuck in the water actually hurts
the boat more than not moving at the
ultimate edge of the speed and so what
has now happened is rather than
everybody looking up to the pulpit of
the New York Times what we have much
more of now is something where yes some
platforms are higher than others but you
have individuals people with millions of
followers like PewDiePie who have more
reach on YouTube than any brand or
corporation so now what you have is
nobody really knows where to look
there's nobody at the front and it seems
like we have this cacophony of noise
and as a result we don't have the same
kind of consensus that we had for the
majority of the post-world War 2 era
yeah this is one of the most fascinating
thing so we went and Joe who's sitting
here in the room and I went and looked
at we compared many of the most popular
television shows to the Joe Rogan just
the YouTube channel right so not audio
Joe Rogan gets on average a million or
more views per YouTube video right in
terms of you kind of I but we didn't do
you know exact math but but you kind of
look there are very few if any TV shows
in America that consistently do a
million views right and so you look at
it you say is that also similar to
PewDiePie who has you know millions of
subscribers millions of views etc is
that because people are choosing to
subscribe because they believe in trust
those individuals over the mainstream
media is it because actually people
don't want to pay for the you know cable
or whatever it is and so these are on
different platforms so it's a platform
advantage or is it actually that those
individuals are willing to talk about
things going to your idea of consensus
they're willing to talk about ideas that
the mainstream media is not willing to
talk about right you see this with kind
of the the meme around epstein didn't
kill himself and always kind of stuff
right that's not a conversation in the
mainstream media for the most part is it
one of those three or is it kind of not
one thing and you get a blending of
there's a whole bunch of factors and
trends coming together and that's why
we're seeing the the kind of degradation
of the you know media institution or the
content that comes out of those
institutions yeah so the what what
you're seeing is there's been a big
convergence of tactics that a lot of the
mainstream media there's just a ruthless
competition for eyeballs and it's I
understand why journalists who have to
get eyeballs have done this but they
have what they've done is they've
adopted a lot of the bloggers tactic
the original bloggers fear sort of too
exaggerated this is something like
Gawker there were sensationalized
stories and they were according to the
US government rule on the teal case they
were invading people's privacy and what
you had was a lot of what that was was
now that anyone could share there was a
competition for trying to come up with
the most sensational stories but this
has been happening for hundreds of years
going back to yellow journalism in the
late 19th century but we have seen time
and again that many of the most
sensational stories went out and it was
the bloggers who were first to take
advantage and what you've seen is this
kind of convergence and unfortunately it
has polluted a lot of a lot of the
Commons but I think that there's some
other things going on here where if you
look and you actually talk to
journalists many are scared because
they're seeing their friends being laid
off when I so I was a journalism major
in college so my full intent was to
actually go become a journalist I wanted
to go become a television anchor and I
would talk to my friends who would do it
they were getting paid like twenty eight
thousand dollars to move to these small
markets and you know what's weird about
journalists often at least the ones I
knew they're they're mostly not paid
very well but they are so smart
like in college the journalism majors
who I knew were some of the smartest
people in my entire class and I they
grew very frustrated by the difference
between what they were getting paid and
how talented they were and I don't blame
them a lot of them are resentful but I
worry that that resentment has now
filtered into many of the mainstream
publications and I think we're feeling
it in our public discourse yeah
so I absolutely agree that and I ain't a
step further like part of the failure of
the mainstream media has been that
journalists who were trained on ethics
process right language all the things
that a traditional journalist goes
through they all sort of masquerading as
bloggers right which meant that if you
look at what the content they create on
Twitter if you look at the language they
use if you look at the lack of kind of
rigid process right even some ethical
components we've seen right whereas
Gawker or others that they get
compromised and part of it is because
the incentives drove them there exactly
right and I'm talking about more the
financial incentives so we need to drive
clicks how do we drive clicks well maybe
we don't hold exactly to this very rigid
process we have you know we can kind of
skip some cut corners etc but also some
of it's a social capital associated with
it right if you're somebody who has
spent four years in college studying
journalism you went to that small market
then you went to a little bit bigger
market a little bit big and all of a
sudden you spent 25 years as a
journalist and nobody knows who you are
no one reads your stuff compared to the
guy who sets up WordPress and just
starts firing off you know hot takes and
next thing you know he's got a million
people reading everything he writes
right or the woman who jumps on you know
Twitter or Instagram and just starts
creating content next thing you know
like everyone trusts that person I think
that someone that is social capital Envy
almost right of like I have that talent
right I have this training I've put the
work in but I don't have the same result
and therefore is are they actually
questioning the process that they've
been following and saying the world is
different now right I was trained on on
one way but now I need to go do this
other that's a really good point and
I've never framed it like this but you
just gave me an insight so when I was in
college we were trained on the ethics of
journalism and we were I was tested on
media law I was tested on following ap
style guide stuff like that and now if
you look at what it is I'm laughing cuz
I'm thinking is there a Twitter ap style
there definitely is it so now what it
takes to become a successful journalist
is much more business savvy of the
ability to understand how to sell a
subscription the ability to understand
how
to actually build an audience and now
like traditionally there was a big wall
in journalism there were sales people in
the organization and then there were
journalists on the other side and there
was very little cross-pollination
between them and they didn't really like
each other and they right so now what
we've had is journalists so bill bishop
he writes a newsletter about China I did
some back of the envelope math cynicism
cynicism just hosted on sub stack which
has a very very very big fan of so I did
the back of the envelope math and he
makes somewhere between a million and
1.2 million dollars per year based on
his subscriptions that is a damn good
living and that is because he's been
able to cross the chasm between those
two things well and just starting
erupted but he was for those that are
not believe he was a traditional
reporter at Axios and started writing on
the side around China and it grew and it
grew and it grew when subsets got
created which for those they don't know
sub stack is basically a platform that
lets you have an email newsletter and
you can sell subscriptions against it
rights people will pay you for it
it got to the point where he said I
there's no reason for me to be
traditional journalists I should just go
do this full-time because he's making
you know quite a good living and he
jumped and so he literally quit the
traditional world to go kind of be his
own boss yeah you know this is sort of
an idea that I haven't really thought
through so let's do it
so I think that there was a kind of
redistribution in the old method of
journalism where it was very hard for
top-tier journalists to actually
quantify how popular they were so I
guess you could do it with who's
speaking at Davos how many people write
letters to the newspaper but it's very
hard to know for example that I like
David Brooks at the New York Times and I
subscribed for that person so what I
think happened is that the really good
journalists were paid less than they
were worth and they actually almost
subsidized the rest of
journalism required to actually fill the
newspaper and so you had all these other
journalists who say we're making $50,000
a year roughly what they were worth but
then you had the people at the very top
who were bringing in millions of dollars
worth of subscriptions who or maybe only
paid $200,000 and I think that they were
serially underpaid and so now what
you're seeing is those people and it's
the bill bishops and the Ben Thompson's
who write at strategy that are sort of
proving out this theory and I think it's
true that now what we're seeing is those
top tier journalists are getting paid
what they're worth and it's funny
because we're living in a world right
now where journalism is seen as not a
good way to make money I predict that by
the end of the decade there'll be
hundreds of journalists making millions
of dollars per year and we're gonna see
the journalism return to a I hope so
because the world needs it I hope that
then these top people are paid what
they're worth yeah and part of this was
I think that subsidy not only was
happening internally but externally one
of the metrics that people would use to
kind of measure who's more popular I'm a
Twitter follower yeah hmm right and that
actually has nothing to do with you know
writing long-form content and Twitter
followers well you may be a better
writer but I'm better than you at
Twitter so I have more followers right
it does not really kind of a one-to-one
comparison it's the world's weird
right when you start getting into
financial incentives and social capital
incentives I think it can get kind of
out of hand and and frankly that's what
we're seeing now with with Twitter also
right is how many of those traditional
journalists are firing off the hot takes
right and now we're actually seeing you
know one of the recent stories is there
was a CEO in New York away his name of
the company where they make luggage and
basically there was an article written a
nutritional outlet there's a bunch of
outrage on Twitter which just Twitter
you know has that outraged culture and
can kind of fuel that the CEO decided to
step down and then a couple of weeks
later the CEO said wait we kind of
overreacted to the Twitter mob and now
I'm gonna step back in they'd already
hired another CEO so now we're gonna be
co-ceos all of that I don't
what's true what's not true what's right
what's wrong etc but the fact that the
Twitter mob became blank you know they
were blamed for overreaction I think
there's a lot of people are sitting
there saying wait a minute are there now
going to be situations where when that
that Twitter mob comes calling for
somebody or the canceled culture etc
people just say look we're gonna wait
alright we're gonna so we're gonna kind
of let the dust settle and see what the
facts are which is what journalism used
to be right you didn't actually have to
just who's the first one to fire off a
tweet it was let me go talk to sources
let me get information let me confirm
facts and then tomorrow's newspaper I
can kind of lay it out and the very kind
of well thought out way Twitter kind of
ruins some of that but it fuels like
there's this undertone of people saying
you know maybe maybe being patient is
actually a good thing in some of these
scenarios yeah I mean look at The New
Yorker The New Yorker you said the
editor used to just give people hey
here's six months use here's a year go
explore what you want dive super deep
into it and then come back to me and
sometimes eat those absolutely
you say those above-average stories
weren't run because there were great
stories that got ahead of them and now
we don't have that now there's too much
of the media is trying to just produce
more and more and more and more
hey there's zero marginal cost of a new
article there's infinite shelf space we
don't have to deal with this the New
York Times famous slogan was all do all
the news that's fit to print it implies
scarcity implies constraint now hey new
article free to do let's just get more
traffic I had a conversation with a
reporter at one of the big three media
companies in New York and they told me I
cannot believe they said this sometimes
it is my job to write faster than I can
think I I have to write some days
between 5 & 7 articles a day I'm
exhausted and it frustrates me that
pageviews is the biggest thing I'm in
valuated on if that sentence that idea
doesn't capture the essence of what
media is right now I don't know what
does it makes sense because that's what
the incentives are right hit like ok any
pages did you sell that
what's the downside of kind of the the
subscription economy and the I pay
directly you for content right but but I
don't get it if I don't pay yeah so it's
that information that's free liberate so
many people information is something
that you used to learn about the world
it gives you access to things he
wouldn't have access to look at me I was
a college kid in North Carolina the
reason that I was given access to ideas
and information is because of Twitter's
ad-supported model because of Facebook's
ad-supported model so we love to hate on
advertising advertising is the death of
democracy and look I've read attention
merchants by Tim Tim Wu I agree there's
a lot of bad things with advertising but
at the same time if advertising doesn't
democratize information I don't know
what does I've spoken to countless
people in other parts of the world who
have been able to start their learning
journey because information is free and
we effort izing is important because it
gives information to people who don't
have the means to pay for it for sure
you said earlier that you think by the
end of the decade there were reporters
who are making millions of dollars a
year I don't think that you are wrong
but I know that another thing that you
believe is that we will start to see
teenage billionaires explain kind of how
you get to that and how you see that
playing out because that's probably to
me one of the more controversial
thoughts that you have but controversial
for those who haven't critically thought
about this stuff I'm in the camp of I
think you're much more right than wrong
that that's gonna start happening yeah
there's I'm like I would put money on I
what that happens I would put money that
there will be a billionaire teenager by
the by 2030
how old is Kylie Jenner do we know I
don't know but if somebody wants Jo
what do we go and go for it
but if someone wants to say that doesn't
count that's fine so probably the
structure structure the parameters of
this saying you need to start with some
net worth below whatever right so like
you can't you can't be rich and famous
basically during your childhood because
of family inheritance whatever 21 so she
wasn't a teenager so basically what's
happening right now is it is getting
easier and easier to start a big company
with just your computer and you have
kids who have access to computers and
they're able to do some create
tremendous wealth for themselves and
what I've seen so I've seen a couple
little points here so whatsapp when it's
sold to Facebook for I think nineteen
billion dollars had only 55 engineers
something like that I just had so one of
my very good friends named Annie McCune
he just sold a company to Squarespace at
24 that he started I did the the actual
acquisition prices and out but they had
25 million users I think 2 million who
were paying $20 a year subscription so
they were making pretty solid money and
he was building he built earth the
Instagram handle which has 1.5 million
followers he started that when he was in
high school and he didn't go to college
and he built millions of dollars of
wealth in 18 months my point being
you're seeing their early signs of
tremendous wealth being created by
younger and younger people and you can
all basically you could almost build a
billion-dollar company from the phone in
your pocket and then there are probably
some things that you would need a
keyboard to do the fact of the matter is
you no longer need to go buy a big
factory you no longer need to go
manufacture airplanes get an energy
plant kids have tools and technology and
what you have is this weird inversion
take the legal profession
the best lawyers well we say the best
lawyers are the people who have done the
most schooling they went to law school
that went to Harvard they worked
whatever and our Supreme Court justices
are quite old and so we say the older
you are the more educated you are the
better of a lawyer you're gonna be
technology kind of inverts that paradigm
in some ways we're who is the best at
making tick-tock videos it is not auntie
sue at the Thanksgiving table right or
the Supreme Court justice right although
I'll throw in is Rebekah I'm a big fan
of in our building they have TVs in the
elevator and they always study these
weird facts out and so people probably
heard me talk before the first time I
started paying attention was I read that
dogs can get sunburned okay okay
different kinds of dogs different levels
of Sun burned all I said was dogs did
you know that golden retriever what I
saw today was Justice John Roberts I
think is the name of Supreme Court
justice in some either proceeding or
writing used the phrase okay boomer in
an age discrimination case and so we
might be careful that the the Supreme
Court justices aren't on tick-tock suit
okay but but continue with your point
well my point is that young people
technology inverts the law paradigm
meaning that for certain skills actually
being young as an advantage and if there
isn't a teenage billionaire by the end
of the decade there will absolutely be a
teenager who's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars so how about vitalic
so vitalic what was he worth at peak
aetherium oh I don't know a lot at least
hundreds of millions for sure so that's
not that far I mean he started that when
he was a teenager right I think he might
have again been young 20s young joining
us here in a second so yeah he's worth
low hundreds of millions low nine
figures when did he start aetherium
chosen 14 so to say look at what is ages
now my point is no matter how old he is
were now just much younger like a
standard deviation this isn't like some
radical paradigm shift yeah
so yeah so he was either late teenage 18
19 or or in those 20 years now you talk
about this inversion another inversion
that I think is playing into this and
actually gives me more confidence
historically what companies have done in
entrepreneurs is they build a product
they put the company and then they go
build distribution right so what's our
product okay who do we want to sell it
to and it's very sequential in that now
what we're seeing kylie is a great
example right and others is no no I'm
gonna go build the distribution and then
I'm gonna build the product right if you
think about it if you had to choose you
would absolutely want to build the
distribution before the product right
because it is much higher percentage
chance of success if you get the
distribution the product is kind of
actually an afterthought but but there's
a high probability you can get a big
audience to buy something the reverse is
not true a lot of people build products
they never get sales because they can't
get distribution down and so the phone
right order the technologies that these
young kids are using they're actually
building the distribution whether they
realize they're doing it or not because
they're building audiences those
audiences give them influence and so
there's this massive shift underway of
like how some of these companies get
built that I think plays very nicely
into this trend of like there's gonna be
teenage billionaires totally I mean this
has been the subtle thread through what
I've done is I didn't know what company
I wanted to start and if you don't know
a company want to start the best thing
to do is start writing online so I'm
obsessed with this idea where so I'm
gonna go a little bit macro where the
American Dream is not what it used to be
if you go Raj Chetty he's an economist
at Harvard if you go on his website
opportunity insights he's gonna win a
Nobel Prize another prediction what you
see is a downward sloping curve from the
Northwest to the southeast and the curve
is the percentage of kids who made more
money than their parents and it's going
orth west to the south e yes so it's
going from the top left of the curve to
the bottom right
or of the graph and what you see is it's
getting harder and harder for kids
millenials people like me to follow the
traditional path and have it be
successful for them we're seeing what I
call credential inflation where you have
all these people who are thirty years
old they have say three credentials they
have a bachelor's a masters and a PhD
and they can't find a job and there are
a hundred thousand dollars in debt I
mean it's tragic you know and so what I
think is also we're seeing a collapse in
the startup formation rates for America
there's all this attention on Silicon
Valley Google Facebook Amazon Netflix
Google we're in the golden age of
entrepreneurship
well actually the data shows the
start-up rates and entrepreneurship are
also going way down the number of
companies being started or the success
of them the number of companies started
interesting or going way down and so
across many different axes American
dynamism is falling and the American
Dream I think is to be able to have
financial freedom and to rise up so you
can buy a house and and and live a good
life and so what I increasingly think is
that the new American Dream is that it
is getting easier and easier to start
companies because you can now build
these audiences you couldn't really do
that 20 years ago and you can use plug
in play software like teachable so for
the for faretta passage we we use
teachable we use oome and I use
convertkit to send my emails these are
amazing pieces of software I don't pay
very much for them and I can do plug and
play I don't know how to code and I have
a software enabled business how crazy is
that
so it's getting easier and easier to
start these companies I went early in my
career was terrified terrified of
automation which is actually what led me
to that personal monopoly idea I knew
that if I had a skill that could be
retrained OOP by that's the Southeast
Asia skill it's gonna be run by somebody
in India Vietnam or Indonesia or it's
gonna be automated by robots so I tried
to build a skill that couldn't be but
the flipside of global competition for
jobs is also global opportunity for
customers so what you can do is you
can build this kind of global audience
then for your product you now sell to
that global audience and what I think is
basically what I want to do eventually
with rite-of-passage
is I want people I have built an
audience that's done rite-of-passage is
fantastic now I want to help people
build a product how do we do that scale
ibly and then how do we actually scale
up those businesses and I just want to
take tens hundreds of people every year
get them to $200,000 in money that they
make once you hit $200,000 you can
support a family and it's your business
you have full freedom you don't have a
lot of employees with these software
companies and I'm just obsessed with how
do I give that to thousands of people
so you hit on one of the ideas that I
used to not tell people this because I
felt like it was kind of Peter Thiel
like goes a secret I knew that no
there's either didn't agree with
automation while it crushes the
repetitive kind of somewhat
intellectually non-stimulating jobs
it actually makes one skill very very
valuable that's creativity yes right and
so the more that the machines can do the
monotonous work actually there's going
to be this premium placed on creativity
and so if you think about creativity
exists today and there's gonna get a
premium is it that the like the the
price for the value of creativity
increases or is it actually that today
we underpriced the creativity and it's
merely going to expose the true value of
the creativity right like you can either
say it's undervalued or hey it's
correctly valued today but over time it
will increase either way it becomes more
valuable than we look at it today which
i think is a really important thing for
people to understand is the thing with
that skill development right exactly so
I would the way that I would phrase it
is that you have more leverage on your
creativity so if I write a Howard Marks
when he started at at oaktree he would
write a memo a letter well he actually
sent that letter to people he would put
it in the mail and he would put stamps
on it and it would go out to all of his
investors I've read every single one of
them I think he started in nineteen
seven
- and they are fantastic I'm Liz
information and how do you read them now
on the computer you go on the computer
right so he presses publish and now
voila
he doesn't have to do that work so you
have more leverage on your creativity
because when he presses publish and you
go on that website might be hosted on
Amazon Web Services which has robots
running automatically to keep that AWS
machine and that website going so he has
automation working for him already and
creatives
are now able to capture value from their
work in ways that they didn't used to be
I've become decent friends with a french
artist named Elora big fan of her her
work she does these kind of hyper
realistic photographs which then she
touches up of Japan and she her
background is in video game design she's
like 24 years old and I started buying
her buying her art I just thought it was
amazing and she was grew up in rural
France was living in Japan at the time
and now she makes enough money that
that's what she does because she goes
and she goes on society6 and she sells
her paintings so my point here is that
Howard Marks he can with he just has
more leverage when he presses published
that can reach anyone with an internet
connection 24 hours a day seven days a
week and then my friend Elora she's now
able to sell her art she doesn't need to
move to New York and go to Sotheby's and
start selling her art whatever or go to
Chelsea to the art galleries she doesn't
need to go through these institutional
gatekeepers anymore she can go on the
internet build her Twitter following
she's crushing it and I love it
yeah it's really crazy how the
distribution channels have drastically
changed and I think a lot about
globalization right so part of even ten
years ago right so 2010 the connectivity
wasn't there right so if you think of
most companies technology companies they
got built you know start in the United
States there to penetrate the US market
and then it was a big boardroom decision
let's do international
and in 2012 well you can only expand as
far as the internet was right there was
a lot of countries a lot of populations
that didn't have internet access didn't
have devices right now for the most part
you see a lot of more internet coverage
right I don't know the latest numbers
but but there's billions of people who
are connected to the Internet who have
devices etc and so when you start a
company right things like stripe things
like Shopify things like teachable you
know all stuff you can have a global
business on day one right and I think
that that is so so powerful but it goes
back to another trend that we see in
technology which is I don't think that
the whole like I want to build a venture
back software company that's either a
billion dollar company or zero is going
to be as sexy as I want to build a
business that can provide me a living
and I actually want less employees I
want profitability and I want kind of
control and those two things are very
different paths to pursue you know kind
of different strokes for different folks
but I do see a resurgence in that idea
of I want to build a a kind of personal
business very similar to what we saw
before the internet existed with small
businesses right people wanted to build
businesses that serve their community
well now that community isn't
geographically based it's kind of
interest-based to some degree absolutely
we had in our third cohort of right of
passage
six months after it started a hundred
ninety six students from 28 countries
really 28 different countries of
students we had a guy named dozy who
would stay up in Nigeria 3:00 a.m. he
would show up to the live sessions one
of my best students Anna fàbregas she
was in Panama she would show up we had a
guy named Victor in the Ukraine and we
would all come together to talk about
writing and that's pretty cool it's it's
it's it's it's just amazing to watch us
all come together and how global this
thing already is and to your point about
about the globalization is one of the
big constraints now isn't Internet
access for me it's time zones where I
can't have more students because a lot
of students want to
therefore the live sessions but still my
second biggest market is India I have so
many Indian students and I love them
because they're consistently the
hardest-working people in my course and
the big thing for us is what do we do
with time zones and time zones are
actually gonna be one of the constraints
on this new global economy yeah
what are some other trends that you're
super excited about kind of an
intersection of media and Technology
influence and kind of business building
writing etc yeah I think that I'm gonna
just phrase this a little bit
differently um one of the things that
I've been thinking a lot about this is a
bit tangential but just cities there's
been a lot of the economic so I'll talk
about the economic consensus where I
agree with it and we're sort of their
big blind spot so I have this idea
called the merry-go-round that cities
are a literal merry-go-round what is a
merry-go-round it spins it spins it's
kind of a party there's all these horses
and weird people and and and there's
sort of themes there's music it's sort
of a party and then you're off the
merry-go-round you're like whoa I want
to be on that thing right and I actually
think cities are very similar where
what's happening is the economic returns
to being in cities are increasing I
think that 50% this was a Axios idea 50%
of American growth last year came from
something like the top 5 or 25 American
cities so basically the main point here
is that the the quote that the reporter
uses is success in America increasingly
hinges on one variable where you live
and so I think that I spent I wanted to
really spend some time in America so I
spent 18 days in Michigan last summer
and I saw a lot of factory towns that
had been hollowed out and I went to
Michigan because I saw a stat that like
in 1955 of the 10 wealthiest cities in
America were in the state of Michigan
now none of the top ten are and then I
did from like car manufacturing exactly
in in early World War two this that is a
little bit disputed so take it with a
grain of salt but the
troit economy had a bigger economy than
every single country in the world except
for something like France Russia and
Britain like everything except for three
or four countries Detroit was a hotbed
of Economic Opportunity and we're still
seeing the same thing where you moved to
New York and San Francisco there's so
much opportunity here there's this
dynamism but we're not building new
housing the transportation is awful our
infrastructure is crumbling we build the
second Avenue subway the new queue line
it costs two billion dollars a mile I
mean come on you can't get to it I was
looking it was cheaper to get to JFK by
helicopter than by uber because the
traffic is so bad so we have what's
happening here is we're not allowing
more people to move to cities so you're
seeing this increase in pricing and to
go back to the merry-go-round metaphor
it's spinning faster and faster so it's
becoming this sort of Club for people
who have access an opportunity but it's
getting harder and harder to get on and
so what though the economists are
missing is cities while they're good for
Economic Opportunity are not good for
community I have felt at times
especially my first two years in New
York tremendous bouts of loneliness it
was really hard for me to meet people I
still in order to go hang out with
friends tonight have to take 40 minutes
subway and it's bizarre how you can walk
down Fifth Avenue at 6:30 at night and
you have thousands of people that you're
looking at and yet somehow you feel like
you are in your own echo chamber like a
London phone booth that you're just
trapped in and that you can't actually
talk to any of those people and my worry
is that cities are places without
community and that economists by telling
people to move to cities we devalue
rural life we devalue the social
institutions that have kept them so
strong as communities for so many years
and the ultimate question that I have is
how can we create cities that are big
enough to give people Economic
Opportunity but small enough to give
people love and
people in their lives that touch their
heart one of the stats I saw recently
there's been two articles in The New
York Times that have been written about
housing in New York City and it's
specifically touching on luxury condos
so from 2010 to 2020 our chosen 19
really there's this big boom in
construction right and between 2010 and
2015 there was massive sell-through
meaning that they built apartments or
luxury condos they sold out of inventory
what does that mean build more build
more build more and there was this kind
of really big push now obviously you
don't snap your fingers and build a
building so there's some kind of lag
between we need more housing let's build
the housing where we gonna build it
what's the design construction okay now
you can buy it
what percentage of luxury condos that
have come on to the market in Manhattan
since 2015 do you think have been sold
thirty four okay fifty fifty fifty
percent have been unsold part of that is
foreign dollars aren't flowing right
kind of as well as they used to flow to
is the cost right and three is a lot of
the sentiment that you're talking about
where other areas right outside of the
island of Manhattan have become more
popular Brooklyn except there's no kind
of pull people away the other article I
read is they were trying to estimate and
there wasn't really kind of a clear
answer how many apartments that are
above I forget the cutoff of the floor
are empty in New York City and it's
again material double-digit percentages
or not even unsold meaning that hey you
can come by it but unrented as well and
so the whole idea was you've built all
of this stuff by projecting demand but
the demands not there and so if you
understand economics it's either which
it built isn't good so supply issue
right or there's too much supply or the
pricing is wrong right there's a
mismatch of the supply and demand that
stuff moves in cycles but
one of the buildings that they talked
about and I won't say who what it is
because Frank I don't know enough about
it but this one building it was like 40%
has been sold red this luxury building
built two years ago and so I was reading
through the article and it said they've
now started to do rent to own so they
want to sell nobody wants to buy so
they'll do rent to own you basically go
in and rent for a year they contribute
that towards the purchase price and you
can buy and so I said that's interesting
I've never heard of a luxury building
doing rent to own in New York so I went
into the website the available units
started at four million dollars and went
up to seven million and I sitting there
and say no wonder you're not selling any
who is gonna buy a you know 1200 square
foot unit for seven million dollar care
what the view is I don't care what floor
you're on you know all this kind of
stuff and what ends up happening is kind
of that feeling of the London phone
booth right how many people are actually
seeking the community and and other
aspects of where they live then just I
got a really nice place with a nice view
and I'm willing to pay you know seven
million dollars for it right I mean that
that's asinine for 99.9% of people in
the world to think about but that is a
problem in one of the most prosperous
cities in the world yeah yeah if two
comets are that so the first one is how
many people live in cities and they look
at suburbs and they say I don't like the
suburbs because you don't know your
neighbors you basically live in your own
enclosed environment and you just live
in this place that feels modern and kind
of without character the funny thing is
a lot of these hot tall new buildings
have the exact same character absolutely
people get in the elevator they don't
even don't know their doorman the places
have no character I just find it funny
that now we're actually importing
suburbs into the sky of cities but and
this is gonna be a little bit
complicated but I think it's worth it
because because it's so interesting but
I think that we have these very so I was
looking at the San Francisco housing
market and what you're seeing is you're
seeing more poor people and more wealthy
people and the middle of the market is
being driven out so Bay
simply the middle-class in San Francisco
is going away and part of it is that for
a lot of high-rise buildings what ends
up happening is they get subsidies to
build low-income housing and it is so
expensive the construction costs are so
high and the regulatory environment is
so what Patrick Allison calls the
promiscuous distribution of veto power
which i think is an amazing term but
what you have is it is so hard to build
now that unless something is at the high
end of the market you can't actually
return the money and the investment that
you spend so then what you have is at
the high end of the market you have all
of this unused supply wares at the
middle end of the market if you actually
look for an apartment in New York
it is so competitive like you find an
apartment boom gotta get on that and I
was talking to my real estate agent
about this and he said that something
kind of flips at around 4,000 per month
where basically there's a lot of
liquidity especially like under 3500 per
month and then you get up and all of a
sudden the entire market changes and you
get into some of the dynamics that you
were talking about it's crazy right and
the part to me that and this gets into
some of the crypto stuff right five
years ago I didn't understand a lot of
the macro economy the systems etc and as
you kind of learn about it what you find
is it's all structural right and the two
components are there's a lack of
financial literacy people don't
understand how money works and what to
do with their money and the second is
the way that the dollars said I'm right
and kind of the the inflationary nature
of it and what is inflation inflation is
I'm going to debase your currency so
it's literally going to get less and
less valuable every day but if you think
about it 50 percent of Americans live
paycheck to paycheck
they have no investments right they
store 100 percent of their wealth in
cash and they believe quote-unquote
saving is the way that you build wealth
the problem with that is that saving is
simply you're putting your wealth into a
currency that is being devalued away so
rather than have any sort of rate of
return which you're seeing is actually a
negative rate of return right and I
think that that lack of financial
literacy combined with kind of
actual component right there's positives
to inflation as well they want to they
want to incentivize economic activity
right and consumption all stuff but if
people don't understand it what ends up
happening is they've been told their
whole lives save instead there's a
combination of you should save us some
rights on some level but you should also
invest right and I think that there's a
gentleman Mourad Mohammed if I don't I
don't know if you've come across him but
Murad was the first one to talk about
this with me which is we asked anyone of
any profession a teacher a firefighter
you know whatever to be good at their
job and to also be a professional
investor that's how you protect your
wealth in America right is you've got to
understand what you do for a living how
you make income but then you also have
to understand how to invest and
investing can be you're actively
managing something you're investing in
passive vehicles or maybe you go and
hire a professional right but if you
don't do that you can't protect your
wealth or you can't grow your wealth and
so it becomes this really interesting
kind of structural psychological
sociological geopolitical issue that
that's where the middle class goes right
they get pushed one way or the other and
to me I always just chalk it up to it's
the people who understand the rules of
the game the people who know the rules
they actually usually tend to thrive
because they understand how to play but
the people who don't understand the
rules they have this sense of I can
never get ahead I'm always behind I
can't get ahead I can't get ahead and I
think that's really where you see that
feeding into how housing is built how
societies and cities and all this stuff
comes together the hope is that crypto
can in some form or fashion right
depending on who you talk to can change
that or influence that to kind of
improve the world right all right he's
got to go in five minutes so I got one
question for you you are friends with
many people who are very educated and
enthusiastic in the Bitcoin in crypto
world give us an overview of what you
know in terms of and then what your view
is as a quote-unquote outsider so
someone who doesn't spend all day on
this well let me just talk by my actions
I am super bullish on Bitcoin I
fundamentally believe that bitcoin is
going
to be a very transformative part of the
next thirty years why because of what
you're talking about with inflation I
think a lot of people don't want to
trust any government with with with
their currency and a lot of people in
other countries outside of America think
that like for example people in China
what I hear about the Chinese economy is
that that currency is sort of on
quicksand and I think a lot of people
feel that way a lot of for example
apartments here that we were talking
about people are trying to get their
money out of China out of parts of
Europe parts of Russia and they're
trying to get their money into big
apartments here and that's why some of
the prices of New York real estate has
been inflated and then at the same time
I know I've had two people come to top
of my mind this week who said America's
doomed and so you've had the American
currency which has basically run the
world since the Bretton Woods conference
after World War two and people no longer
have that same trust right it's just
like where you're talking about I think
a lot of wealthy people they're not
happy about taxes in America and you
have different movements like
seasteading and stuff like that or
people trying to move to other parts of
the world where their taxes aren't as
high and then you have people at who
maybe aren't making as much money who
feel screwed by the system you have
cantle in effects right you have
inflation pumping in the economy and
it's going to people at the top before
it's going to people at the bottom
that's that's a rigged system for people
who know the rules and so to get back to
me I believe all those things and yet I
don't own Bitcoin why because I don't
want to go on coin base and pay the fees
I wanna do it right with what are the
crypto wallets you know where I sprinkle
nail polish on it and all that thing and
I just like I just don't I mean part of
it too is I fundamentally I'm so bullish
and believe so much and right of passage
that I think that the rate of return
that I can get on investing my business
is higher but also any real rational
calculus here would say dude put one or
two percent of your money in Bitcoin and
I just haven't done it even though I'm
surrounded by because you think it's
hard to do yeah it's hard to do it's
confusing what if I lose the key uh I
don't know I mean it's just like it's
kind of scary buying Bitcoin it's like
am I doing this right it still kind of
feels like this new future thing that
might not be legit even though I believe
in it it's funny it's like it's always
weird when you have these these these
weird cognitive dissonance --is where I
have like theoretically I really believe
in Bitcoin but obviously I have some
kind of aversion to it oh this is big -
I my family would think that's so crazy
and and so it would turn into such a
what are you doing with your money
conversation and as a result I just
haven't bought bit court I intend to
change that and it kind of bothers me
but that's why I love that view though
you're super rational about why you
don't own it like you both you believe
but you just are like hey it's hard I I
just know crypto is the future like I
just believe in it so or at least
Bitcoin like I really believe in Bitcoin
and but I mean me and origin we're gonna
get you over to get you hooked up right
before the so what what is the what's
the most important book you've ever read
understanding media by Marshall McLuhan
why so Marshall McLuhan was a member I
was talking about the space and time
bias so Marshall McLuhan was a media
theorist who wrote in the 1960s and
don't actually read the book listen to
his interviews he actually did an
interview on with Playboy magazine which
is the very best Marshall McLuhan
interview and then YouTube Terence
Mckenna fifty-three minute break down of
Marshall McLuhan's ideas they absolutely
transformed how I saw about the how I
looked at the world because what the
book is called
is his most famous book is called
understanding media but he didn't define
media as the media that we were talking
about he defined media as technology
things that actually mediate our senses
so for example the wheel as an extension
of the of the foot a hammer is an
extension of the hand
and he went all the way back in time
going back to the invention of language
and stuff and looked at what are the
systemic things that happen when a new
technology comes into society and what
happens is you get this big speed-up a
big acceleration and then you get a flip
an inversion which is why I use that
word all the time where we go back and
we retrieve the old and what Marshall
McLuhan has shown me is that what's
happening right now isn't entirely new
and has given me a framework for
understanding shifts in technology that
then I've been able to apply so that I
can have a modicum of calmness in a
vortex of fear and anger right we're
ending right there you're a [ __ ]
legend man
all right listen thank you so much for
coming to do this where can people find
you and rite of passage i'm on twitter
at david underscore paral paral compere
ll calm is my website and rite of
passage is spelled WR ite of passage so
WR te like rite of passage
thank you very much awesome and thank
you so much for coming